this man who's been around a while he's
he's right here on the Rich Eisen show
pleased to have somebody who I've seen
in many a school courtyard since our
kids went to school together back in the
day breakfast bar good to see you man
thanks man
good to have you finally here yes you
got it yes had a few my buddies on Ryan
Phillips tied with him right about 18 we
met at an audition for a movie of the
week
starring Meredith baxter-birney of
course and it came down to the two of us
and he didn't have a ride home I had a
skateboard and a car so I gave him a
ride home and he never left
who got the gig I got the gig I got the
I got the gig and then he and then he
got some other gig you got to have the
extra Bernie experience what's the name
of the film do you remember the name of
the movie trade the story of two women
neither were played by me where did you
that betrays the betrayed woman's son
okay this is who I was it was me
marriage Baxter Swoosie Kurtz it was a
perfect movie though my goodness why
don't they make movies of the week
anymore man Netflix now there's called
movies they just call them below the
stream um yeah that's it if it has a
superhero it's a feature film but if it
has no superhero it's the right movie
the week now you're born it you're born
and raised in Los Angeles Oda more okay
born in Minnesota Minnesota my dad was
working at the University and then I
moved to ROS - so you're like the Lakers
you moved here from Minnesota spinning a
basketball on your finger so are you a
Lakers fan is that I am a Lakers fan I
grew up I grew up here in LA as long as
my hips not acting huh yeah Laker fan
and which there's no I know you were
asking Chris's we're coming on the
coaching situation you know Luke's out
and it he was out for like five minutes
fast what do you think of magic just
tapping out like that man I don't know
man I mean I love magic I I was a very
very young child watching magic and then
growing up seeing him play actually did
a cameo on a TV show like I love magic
to death I don't know what I wish I was
smart enough to know exactly what the
right I need to do I enjoy watching the
hell out of them and stuff but right now
hold on a second so magic showed up on
when Adric did a guest spot on this
sitcom I had I had it was like all these
sports characters were in my head so
like if my character was debating about
whether or not he asked a girl out he
turns over in Mills Lane is there I was
there and so at one point was my
characters like I don't know if I mask
or cut to Bill Walton standing there
going you're gonna score I swear gonna
happen you know all this and so that was
the show and at one point magic was on
and I was sitting with magic we were
doing an elevator scene and they were
like Brecon could you stand up a little
taller and I was like guys he's you know
I'm standing next to magic who's you
know six six and here because these goes
six eight sorry but yeah so magic so
yeah I don't remember Mills Lane on
inside Schwartz I don't was member I
have a boxing glove with the signature
on I made sure to get everyone to sign
everything bo Jackson was on at one
point I said and Bo's hips were really
tough at the time and I said let me ask
you by the way this is an obnoxious
thing to say to Bo Jackson don't ever do
it you can ask your question right now
who would win in a footrace without
missing a beat he liked me and I was
like but you he's like doesn't matter
and it really it was like this the
athlete spirit where he's like yeah it
doesn't matter if I'm hurt or not I'd
crush you cuz it's all I do for a living
you know I wouldn't let you live I
wouldn't let you win you lilliputian boy
so I mean when you start messing with
pride yeah and prideful athletes and
goats
my producer Dom Buies getting in my ear
I guess going down the IMDB page of
inside Schwartz ed Buckner on
Buckner Buckner on and then did you ask
him who could write now who could feel
the ball Bill Buckner came on was lovely
and they said they kind of the producers
Kenny and I didn't I never grew up
knowing baseball very well I didn't know
baseball so I knew the I knew the visual
of Buckner but I know his name really
and so they told me who it was and they
said listen also don't mention it he
hears about it every day of his life
don't mention and I'm like no problem
I'll be respectful Bryan Callen who's a
stand-up who's a show yeah Bryan's one
of the funniest people on the planet
Bryan's there too and they're telling us
together like you know just don't
mention it no screws over it
he comes in bill hey doing Breckin Meyer
nice to meet you he goes Bryan cameras
goes how the hell did you miss it and
Bill just kind of said like never heard
that you know and but he signed all form
Wow
so yeah bill was great he didn't someone
for Callen milla I don't think heard
about talking about the elephant in the
room I mean there was no chance he
wasn't gonna do it it's like comedic
Tourette's he's not gonna say it and yes
we had Buckner on and all these all
these people were pretty made Tony
Gonzalez and I all these people is
really feasible he's about to go in the
Hall of Fame Dick Butkus Dick Butkus I
mean I mean that that's kind of like
football acting royalty and yeah
Dick Butkus is big magic Bill Walton I
mean so where do you keep all these
items so they just in your house I
didn't know how to like display him cuz
it wasn't like they're not mine and it
says yes I know where they are
okay you know Breck admire your on on
the Rich Eisen show so we you had
mentioning you're heading off to play
some golf
I'm gonna go play golf there's uh the
Murray brothers Bill Murray and his
brothers have a cherry thing in st.
Augustine I'm gonna go play in that and
Bill was the voice of Garfield in the -
Garfield movies I did we met once I
think that's it but yeah so yeah and I'm
not a very
come on Brian doyle-murray wrote can
check ok shagging he'll be there and
he's got one of the the famed lines of
Caddyshack to pick up that blood you
know he plays duh oh is that blood play
with them good you don't play you're
just going a little bit I play a little
bit and it's just so time-consuming I
know but you I'm wondering how it hits
you cuz I was able to watch with my kids
Tiger win the Masters yes and that
really I mean I was really a they get
affected make today well I mean in a way
my daughter loves the name Tiger Woods
sure and just again just seeing Tiger he
just looks inviting yeah you know so she
kind of digged it yeah but for at least
my sons I kind of felt like you know
instead of that you know to use the
phrase you used before like the old man
talking about like let me tell you about
Tiger where I started sounding like that
right and now I'm able to say no that
shot on 16 we just saw
he almost jarred it from the tee box
that's the Tiger Woods I'm talking right
on as he's put in the jacket yeah it was
kind of big really neat when the kid ran
his mom was there like all that all for
and also I mean I knock on whatever wood
because I know it's a nightmare that's
what I don't have back pain and I don't
have a back issue right and the fact I
mean their shots where he's you know
holding the holding the holding I don't
know he was on his knees like this guy's
trying to do the one thing he's
incredible at where his body won't let
him right as a nightmare
you know the idea of that so it makes it
that much sweeter when you said they're
glad you actually would have pull it
together and after I don't how many
surgeries had what it's like what three
or four it was insane oh you're by the
way that's what he needs just one yeah
one back surgery I started playing golf
for fun and I wasn't very good at it I
was playing about five months I was
playing with my in-laws at the time and
I had a hole-in-one
and if you've been playing for five
months and have a hole-in-one that
people have been playing forever and
haven't right and they're your in-laws
they don't like you
when that happens and you know so I
stopped for a little bit I was like I
think I'm done I think I think I just I
think I just golf like that was it right
you got a hole-in-one and you're done so
good night it really does it that was it
and I picked up a little bit later we
were doing Franklin a Bosch mark-paul
and I got kind of rebuilt by the bug
we've had mark Paul on here - yeah too
long for you - yeah I mean like we've
had pretty much everyone from your bill
hader first time he's ever open pizza
Breckin Meyer cleaning up here in the
Richard show so what do what do you play
I mean I played badly enough
oddly enough with my statue I play
basketball quite a lot that's my that's
my main addiction you were in that famed
pickup game around this town right I
mean I was yeah I played I played at
Gary Gary Shannon Shandling's game for
about ten years I've I've heard get out
it what in the world was that she would
just have yeah I'd heard about it and
Gary's the best I my makeup artist was
his mainly that's what you get into most
basketball games is here your makeup
artist and my rig of ours was Gary's and
also I knew my makeup artist face
because he was aunt like his like Gary
there's that with Larry Sanders yes his
makeup artists on the show was his
makeup artist Bruce oh really yeah so
Bruce Grayson on the show is Bruce
Grayson his makeup guy right and I
started talking to Bruce about and I
love playing basketball and he invited
me one time and I was then I stayed for
13 years every Sunday I'd go play ball
at Gary's and what was his game like it
was it's really think it's a half-court
it's three on three to play to seven and
by ones and twos and it's a quick game
but it's also the funniest game in the
planet because you got whether it's Will
Ferrell or Judd Apatow or whoever's
there Sasha : whoever happens to be
there and Gary Gary's surprisingly
strong Gary was surprisingly fit he
boxed a lot he actually got me into
boxing
so you'd guard him and you're like ah
ads Gary Shandling is a funny guy and
then you put your arm there and you feel
that body push on you like oh no joke
here okay
funny you know anyways a graves also
because you'd play and then you just sit
around and just talk BS after the game
but it's also your you're just chatting
with the funniest people in the world
right
why was great I've told this story
before and I'll tell you as well but you
know I was fortunate enough to be
introduced to Gary and we had a lunch
and just getting to meet him and hear
his stories and he was just so spiritual
and such a deep guy like telling me
stuff that we've just met right and I
was such a huge fan of his and Larry
Sanders yeah and so I felt comfortable
to say look you know I've got a show an
interview show on on DirecTV yeah and he
watched it and gave me some tips
yeah that's and one of the one of them
was just looking at the layout of this
desk on the chair that you're sitting in
right now yeah he thought it was fanned
out too much that I needed to close it
and he said that the guest needs to be
close enough to basically be sitting on
your lap like he was telling you it's
got to be intimate you got to listen you
got yeah he was awesome he's great and I
suppose the truth and being in the
moment and it's I mean the amazing thing
about Gary is when wengie passed the one
thing that kind of came to light was you
know you've a lot of there's a lot of
comedians who are mentors to other
comedians right Gary was a mentor to
every type of person I mean whether it
was a whether it was a boxer whether it
was Favreau with Ironman and that's and
that was not a comedian is just a
director writer actor and then whether
it was Sasha with Borat whether it was
when I was gonna run i created the show
called men at work then i ran for three
years and yeah on the network when you
were on we were on we're on the Turner
networks and so when I was gonna run a
show it's called a showrunner basically
means you created it near the exact
producer guy and the head writer I
didn't know what I was doing I'd never
written anything before except for Robot
Chicken and this was a linear story is
your live-action and first person I went
over and saw was Gary and I was like how
do I show run what do I do they asked
who the showrunner was I just raised my
hands so how do I do it
and Gary sat me down and it wasn't
here's how you talk to your writers it
was what you're talking about it was
much more of the spiritual side of like
here's how you get in the head
face here's our I'm open to accept
criticism and accept other ideas and
really make this the best thing it can
be whether it's a comedy drama movie
music album whatever he was a mentor to
so many different people and I think
that's why I resonate so much with like
Judds documentary and one yeah that
two-part documentary alright cuz I mean
you wouldn't have you wouldn't have
Modern Family you wouldn't have the
office without Larry Sanders British or
American Russian I mean the amount of
people he touched with his style and his
comedy is kind of unheard of so to play
in that game and then Garry got me
involved at boxing which I became
addicted to going and watching I mean
like actually throwing and watching yeah
he was amazing
Breckin Meyer here on the Rich Eisen
show who do you like watching right now
and I just saw I just went on what was
it Friday and Solomon chenko at was a
Corolla and it's staple I've never been
to a boxing match I'd never gone to one
I watch it all the time but I've never
been to see a pro fight because it was
always Vegas or it really seemed like it
to do sure
and I'm spoiled where I want to sit I
want to have the good seats it sure I'll
watch it home I'm happy to watch it home
the same way would want to go see
basketball it's like I want to hear him
I want to hear them talk and stuff oh
yeah
so when StubHub and bought tickets and I
was ii wrote the loma chenko fight it
was amazing it is so intense you you
should treat yourself to a big Vegas
talk Singh yeah I would love to do with
that and lo mishchenko and there's this
new guy who actually goes to the gym I
go this guy literally kick the crap out
of recess Josh green Josh Graham who has
like don't blink he's got a pillow
that's like it's kind of his signature
things don't blink cuz I'll put you to
sleep he's really fun to watch so it's
been really fun but also because Gary
got me into boxing it's like when you
play basketball if you if you golf when
you watch it it's different now like I
watch boxing them all oh it's it
definitely isn't it's not just two guys
smacking each other
it's a sweeter side yeah you get when
you actually do it tell me about the fix
Breckin Meyer Mondays at 10:00 eastern
time on ABC
yeah the fix is it was its co-written by
Marcia Clark of the OJ fane of the OJ
trial and it's basically kind of like a
she calls it like a revenge fantasy it's
basically like what if oj 8 years after
he got off if his present girlfriend
wound up dead not oj oj tight sure and
it's kind of like Marcia's character
gets a second chance and will she play
dirty this time because last time they
played a little dirty and she lost
playing by the rules will she play dirty
this time my characters kind of he's the
DA so essentially you know gil garcetti
ish and his whole thing is he just wants
to keep it he wants to you know if this
guy wants to be mayor someday so you got
it all his employees gotta do stuff
aboveboard which is definitely not what
they're doing right and that's mayhem
ensues that's on Mondays at 10:00
Eastern exactly tonight so have you ever
sat down with Marcia Clark I mean she's
the showrunner she's there all the time
so did you have you ever enough quietly
answer like what no I wanted to do is I
wanted to get comfortable enough with
her so I figure I gave it a season of
small time what is the general public
not know like what wasn't admissible
that you thought was a slam dunk like is
there a video right is there a video
vote like what's up you know just you
know that's morbid Michael geez my
question would be and I think I asked
this of gil garcetti when he came in to
talk about the OJ made-in-america thirty
thirty to thirty which won an Oscar yeah
was why why did you not bring up the low
speed chase right how is that not
admissible in court like that's the most
guys and all that why were you running
at all if you were innocent right and he
didn't really have an answer for it so I
think you need to help Marcia we
continue to hold Marcia Clark's feet to
the floor
I mean season two happens yeah season
two I mean if we can retry it right now
yeah I'm not sure I mean there's so many
questions about like and also what's
interesting to me about Marcia is she is
I mean she was infamous she was and I
mean nobody was under more of a
microscope for your hair for your
clothes or your legal decisions all
these things and she's kind of risen
from it to become this great author and
she's written these books and she's a
consultant and she's a showrunner now so
it's impressive because
don't know if I'd come back from that I
don't know if I mean you know as an
actor you read reviews and after my
first review where they ever like used
my name yes my first starring role was
movie was road trip and you know I'd
done clueless and stuff a road trip was
like the first one was like first name
was mine oh my god
the review came out in one of the trade
papers and it was a really favorable
review which is great as an actor you
hear and it's great and it says Breckin
Meyer and then in parentheses and it's
it's it's a positive review like an
thing I broke my great whatever it said
was nice but to describe me it said
wreck admire a trash compactor Bill
Maher and praise my performance I will
say if you're referred to as a trash
compactor anything not even Bill Maher
trash compacted is not a great way to
start it but a trash can Baghdad Bill
Maher and then it was a compliment it
was the ultimate example of like
slapping you in the face and then just
helping you up and giving you a little
hug and nothing against Bill Maher no I
mean sure that's great but I don't think
he wanted to be defined as a taffy
stretched wrecking the fix airs Monday
attendees kiss time on ABC channel trash
competitive check it out tonight at
Breckin Meyer on both Twitter and
Instagram good to see you sir human
thanks for coming on this first of many
yes sir for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app